when we talk about imagining afrofutures
we're talking about imagining
tracing and recovering afrofutures and
what does that mean
yeah afrofeatures in 1.0 really emerged
in the 1940s
with sunrah post world war ii
and pre uh emergence of the world wide
web
and that emerged to describe the
african-americans imaginations and
engagement with science fiction
music art technology there's a guy named
helmut
and a voice spoke to him in the early
40s and said hey
you know what black people came from
another planet
you should stop doing what you're doing
work on your music
and this person became sun raw the early
jazz musician who
innovated in jazz and art and created
his own band
that's here with us today and
it really ushered in kind of this wave
of afrofuturism experimentation
with art and music it was going on
before but this is where it really takes
on kind of an otherworldly
feeling let's take a listen to sun raw
for a minute too so you can kind of hear
how he's experimenting with the future
[Music]
we have the mothership connection with
parliament funkadelic
that continues in with george clinton
that music
continuing with that we have public
enemy and their album fear of a black
planet
and then we have illustrious writers
like samuel delaney
and octavia butler samuel delaney etches
out this queer alien world in dahlgren
and octavia butler talks about imparable
the sower
about this miraculous woman who
lives in the year 2020s where
society is collapsing around them they
have a president who ignores
the marginalized and so
she's embodies this empathic power
to be able to feel what people are
feeling and she leads
her community up north to recreate
a new type of world for them